welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and thor love and thunder prove
that whoever you pray to their attention
is divided between you and zeus is a
thunderbolt over 50 gods appeared in
this film some familiar some new some in
omnipotent cities some with a work from
home situation i soon be a raven mail
and while i covered a lot of them in my
full movie breakdown we now got to go
through these one by one a because i
missed a few of them and b because each
god represents a new world of believers
in a new afterlife realm that now exists
in the mcu spoilers for love and thunder
and the best way to support new
rockstars is to check out our new latest
obsession shirt worthy of love because
you are at newrockstarsmerge.com now we
went into this movie already knowing
thor and the other norse gods odin
frigga loki heimdall siff and valkyrie
their afterlife is valhalla which we
finally see in this movie's post-credits
scene this is where asgardians go when
they die in battle but we also got a
glimpse of hell h-e-l that's where hella
was banished to and where loki thought
he woke up in in loki episode four now
omnipotent city is ruled over by zeus
leader of the council of godheads in the
thor comics and the head of the greek
gods his half-mortal son is hercules the
hero who made his mcu debut in the
post-credits scene these gods reside in
mount olympus we also got a sighting of
dionysus who shouts good one dad at one
of zeus's jokes dionysus is a god of
wine there's also artemis she's the
greek goddess of the hunt in this movie
zeus lectures thor every god watches
over their own peoples nothing more
nothing less that implies that each of
these gods is assigned specifically to a
civilization of people who believe in
them zeus speaks in a greek accent in
this movie a modern greek accent but few
if any greeks in modern-day greece
actually pray to zeus anymore the
country's predominantly orthodox
christian so this might explain why zeus
and dionysus and the rest are such
detached partiers and hedonists because
they have no living mortals who take
them seriously anymore now as thor and
the rest enter this golden temple of
omnipotent city they look up to see a
golden dragon who looks like the great
protector of talo in shanghai talo is
depicted as a heavenly realm with
wildlife rooted in chinese mythology we
also went in this movie knowing a bit
about wakandan mythology the panther
deity bost and their afterlife being the
ancestral plane bost appeared in the
black panther prologue and is derived
from the feline deity of bastet in
egyptian mythology who is often paired
with the deity of segment both of these
feline entities mentioned by t'challa in
civil war in my culture
dead
it's not the end
it's marve
stepping off point you reach out with
both hands and bust in segment
they lead you into the green valve where
you can run forever and i actually think
we saw a cameo of segment behind thor
and korg as they enter this temple a
white furred feline sleeping on the
raised platform this thing is roughly
the same size bost was depicted as in
black panther its head looks
panther-esque like this might be a
lighter furred partner to bost now
months ago we reported how one of the
humanoid goddesses sitting in front of
valkyrie and jane is bost or bastet
based on the credit that actress
sakosiya sabit listed in her online
resume which might have been something
she got from a casting director or from
her feline inspired wardrobe but she
doesn't get any lines in this movie and
doesn't appear in the movie's credits
like many of these other gods do so it's
hard to know what to make of this but
speaking of egyptian mythology we did
meet a number of egyptian gods in moon
knight including konchu ahmet tuaret and
the members of the inead seen through
their human avatars osiris horus hathor
isis and tefnut but none of them appear
here though thor earlier name-dropped ra
who is the egyptian sun god we didn't
really see raw in moon knight remember
in that show tawarat showed us the
egyptian underworld of the duat in the
aru the field of reeds and explained how
these were part of an afterlife network
linked with the wakandan ancestral plane
so presumably so is valhalla so is hell
and so are all these other realms that
these gods are linked to now as they
walk through the temple valkyrie points
out a god of magic with wings and a
spiked mask and a god of dreams as the
camera pants up to a giant eyeball now
that winged figure this god of magic
might be the godly form of isis whom in
moon knight we only ever saw in the form
of her human avatar now the god of
dreams in greek mythology is morpheus
but morpheus isn't really ever depicted
as an eyeball valkyrie also points to
someone off screen the god of carpentry
which might be her nickname for jesus
christ a carpenter by trade of course
christianity has already been mcu cannon
from every shot of a church to this line
these guys come from legend they're
basically gods there's only one god man
and i'm pretty sure he doesn't dress
like that and therefore the christian
notions of heaven and hell likely also
exist as realms in the mcu but this
video is brought to you by the ridge the
ridge wallet is light and sleek and
industrial it's designed to fit in your
front pocket unlike those bulky old
school wallets and make you look like
you're smuggling an 80s car phone in
your back pocket check it out there are
over 30 colors including carbon fiber
and burnt titanium it holds up to 12
cards and still has room for cash card
and
gold
dollars this is what they call the black
damascus only the finest for my front
pockets every ridge wallet comes with a
lifetime guarantee and they'll let you
test drive it for 45 days and send it
back for a full refund if you don't love
it the wallets have over 40 000
five-star reviews it's made with an rfid
blocking technology that protects you
from those digital pickpocketers they
also have other cool products like this
commuter backpack it's weatherproof and
great for toting around a laptop this
month actually marks nine years since
the ridge started and they're
celebrating with a special sale so get
15 percent off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com new rockstars that's ridge.com
new rockstars and use code new rockstars
find the link in the video's description
then they point out a couple jokey ones
like bow the god of dumplings and a
cronin god who sits on a throne of
scissors sitting in front of korg is an
aztec god with a feathered headdress
this is likely quetzalcoatl whom thor
mentioned earlier he is the aztec god of
creation there's also a goddess of the
dead in white face paint presumably also
from aztec mythology maybe mikte
khasihuato and with these two by
extension the aztekian land of the dead
mix-lan a version of which we saw in
pixar's coco mcu canon and no i'm not
saying that every disney animated
depiction of some mythological afterlife
is exactly what those afterlifes are
supposed to be in every form of fiction
or in real life but i'm just saying that
the cultural elements that you love from
those films are now established to have
some mcu counterpart which is really
cool there's also a mayan god who
carries a staff and laughs at zeus's
joke this may be it's amna the mayan god
of creation just because all these other
representative gods seem to be the chief
god of that pantheon now black panther
wakanda forever is expected to introduce
namor with some jaguar iconography
tanakhuerta the actor saying that he had
to learn a language based on mayan
there's also a maori goddess presumably
tumatuanga whom thor listed as part of
his dream team earlier now thor also has
to step over a jade eye god who is a
japanese samurai figure and then there
is a goddess with golden discs on either
side of her head this is a very specific
reference the elche goddess based on the
lady of elche a limestone bust that was
recovered in spain that was believed to
be a carthaginian goddess worshiped by
punic cultures who settled the iberian
peninsula in ancient times there's
another god that's credited as minerva
who is the roman goddess of wisdom and
art the equivalent of the greek goddess
athena and then there's my favorite the
fur god now there's also an assortment
of other gods here like two sycophant
gods on either side of dionysus and then
two masked gods and of course we cannot
forget the four emotion gods whom
valkyrie disrobed each color
representing a different emotion and i
love how thor gets the blue one
reflecting how in this movie he is in
korg's words assad god now outside of
this chamber are peaking in two
celestials the mad celestial and a
celestial gardener they are likely part
of the lineup of celestials that
includes ereshim jemiah hargan and nazar
from the eternals film now ego was also
a celestial but he just took a planetary
in humanoid form there were some
murdered gods in this movie that include
rapu who was a sun deity worshiped by
gore's people thaligar the behemoth the
gods of the indigorians and hundreds of
other unspecified gods there were some
rumors of deleted scenes suggesting
these might have included the grand
master e tree and a goddess played by
lena heady elsewhere in the mcu we have
just learned of the elder god k'thon who
wrote to the darkhold and may have been
the source of wanda sorcery and of
course the eternals athena icarus ajax
cersei kingo sprite makari gilgamesh and
bastos and druid they were all seen as
gods that inspired earth's mythologies
but were actually synthetic beings used
by celestials to hatch planets thanos
and his brother eros the god of love
were also eternals from the planet titan
but none of these are technically gods
the way zeus and the others are above
all of these gods are the cosmic beings
depicted in statue form in the chamber
of this movie eternity death eon
infinity the living tribunal the watcher
and the one above all actually the one
above all here takes a celestial form
and we finally actually see eternity's
true cosmic form but it just seems like
eternity in this movie transforms into a
new cosmic entity love which is another
abstract being from marvel lore but the
fact that those seven were stored
together in this chamber suggests that
they're on some tear beyond the gods of
omnipotent city and these seven oversee
the multiverse on an equal status as
opposed to any one of them ruling over
any one particular dominion or culture
so there you go that's easily 50 gods
identified in the mcu and counting and i
did it all without mentioning
you know him you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at you boss
following rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you